es la persona más rica del mundo según
la revista forbes y quizás le sorprenda
saber que paga entre muy poco y nada de
impuestos en eeuu y lo más director
ejecutivo de la compañía de autos tesla
pregunté en twitter este fin de semana
si debería dar un paso que lo haría
someterse a un enorme pago fiscal en una
encuesta preguntó a sus más de 60
millones de seguidores si debería vender
el 10 por ciento de sus acciones en
tesla el 58% respondió con un
contundente si la transacción lo haría
ganar unos 21 mil millones de dólares
que estarían sometidos a los impuestos
para ganancias de capital probablemente
esta venta iba a tener lugar sin
importar lo que pasará más se enfrenta
ya a un pago de impuestos por las
opciones que tiene sobre acciones
valoradas en 15 mil millones de dólares
y ahora que el no ingreso salario o
primas su única manera de pagar
impuestos es a través de la venta de
acciones la agencia propublica publicó
unas filtraciones que demuestran que más
no pagó impuestos de renta en 2018 no
está solo el multimillonario jeff bezos
fundador de amazon no pagó nada entre
2007 y 2011
el presidente de eeuu joe biden ha
estado impulsando la creación tiene un
puesto los multimillonarios para
contribuir a la financiación del bid
back ver su plan de programas sociales y
ayudas el senador ron wyden quien
propuso este impuesto en el congreso
afirmó durante el fin de semana que el
hombre más rico del mundo pague
impuestos o no no debería depender de
los resultados de una encuesta de
twitter es momento del impuesto de renta
para los millonarios más que se
comprometió a cumplir con los resultados
de la encuesta dijo en twitter que
estaba preparado para aceptar cualquier
resultado